there we go david do you say that so
you're the first voice everybody hears
is that what it is
i'm convinced that is your way of doing
it gentlemen start your engines anyways
we are on episode number 85 adam we have
adam back with us phil here but we have
a special guest david harris jr how are
you doing welcome baby how are you
feeling well good day so having me don't
see me hanging we we had a we had a nice
little pre uh a podcast uh
uh uh what do you call a meeting last
night yes short meeting started at two
o'clock in the afternoon ended at
midnight which was a lot of prep a lot
of role play pull all that stuff but
then we had good conversations with
david last night
yourself adam i wish you guys were there
last night adam was
hardcore debating david
trying to convince david how amazing of
a country america is yeah he wouldn't he
wouldn't budge he wouldn't but all i
remember is the legos
do you play legos
how often do people ask you that
question
i don't think i've ever been asked that
question well i mean there's a first
sound for everything you know i was
never asked that question until pat
brought it up yeah yeah so anyways david
for some guys who don't know your story
take a quick moment give him your story
i mean obviously
uh you and i got connected when we first
sat down and we spoke in dallas i think
it was an event going on we uh came down
we had a meeting behind closed doors
spoke and we realized our story goes way
i don't know how many years back goes to
the connection but tell us your story so
the audience knows as well so uh i'm uh
uh from northern california
and uh a christian raised a christian
didn't always walk that path obviously
uh
i don't know of too many people that
were able to stay that true course for
you know just their whole life some have
that's amazing but i had internal
battles and demons and things that i had
to deal with so
um
but always very conservative by by
nature married my high school sweetheart
right out of high school so we just
celebrated 27 years of marriage
through liberal hell beautiful family by
the way thank you brother thank you
been through hell and back but she held
on
uh i held on and we had faith that god
would pull us through when he did kids
two daughters yeah twenty twenty three
and two girls
yeah yep i got two don't look at your
daddy's girl's profile because his
daughters are beautiful by the way so
i'm not looking enough adam seriously
with you we have a code for adam
stick to tinder but go ahead please
continue
so uh entrepreneur humble i'm sorry
please don't get hinges actually
go ahead entrepreneur yeah entrepreneur
started my first company when i was 20.
uh had some seminar success we're doing
a couple of million dollars a year in
business but when you got internal stuff
in there a lot of money it can turn into
a lot of problems and headaches
so um a long story short getting to
where my kind of uh
social media platform started to grow
and hello to anybody out there on
youtube that's hearing me now because i
was banned about a month ago on youtube
my youtube page was unpublished
but what started it was right after the
third debate between trump and hillary
i'm watching this debate i'm hearing
trump talk i'm hearing hillary talk and
i'd seen and been paying attention to
what i felt the mainstream media was
doing taking clips out of context
against trump and then painting him like
this evil racist guy
when everybody loved trump before he ran
for office as a republican yeah i firmly
believe if he would have ran as a
democrat they would have treated him
like obama like the next coming savior
is how they treated obama and i didn't
vote for him i was trying to wake people
up
i have a chapter in my book when when
obama
became president i cried
but it was a it was a it was a cry for
uh of remorse because of who i felt
obama was was not the right leader for
our country
but it was it was strange because it was
also mingled with a black man just
became president so it was bittersweet
for you it's very bittersweet yeah more
bitter than sweet
but uh
yeah anyway i tried to wake people up
because for me
i've always believed
and felt and known
the same i think any child does
towards a baby in the womb
a baby in the womb is a baby
whether it's
inside or outside the womb people know
that kids know that
and i think science proves that now as
well
so for me
there was no way that i could vote for a
man
that believed that abortion was okay
especially partial birth abortion he
voted in favor of partial birth abortion
obama did he voted against a bill that
would have provided medical treatment to
babies that survived abortions
and
when i when i first
found out he was running for president i
was excited to my mom thank god for good
moms i pray for you
and family to pray for you she said go
research
how he votes on the issues that matter
to you and so when i found those things
out on his stance on abortion i said i
don't care what color he is
he's not getting my vote
and i tried to wait
as a conservative you've uh uh you grown
up in the church were you
oh i did until i was about
uh 15 16 and started drinking and were
you ever a democrat were you ever on the
left were you ever never really
political when did you become political
at what age
it was probably obama it was it was the
408 because i mean it was a big thing
for the black community
there's a black guy running for
president yeah right and i think most of
the black community kind of woke up to
saying what they were literally pre-2011
you were never you were never in in
politics you didn't follow it mm-hmm
no wow i mean i followed a little bit
yeah oh eight yeah from eight to 12 to
16. i followed it a little bit did i say
what year did i say
i mean oh seven i mean oh seven meaning
campaign he's coming up so did you hear
him speaking oh four uh did you see his
dnc speech okay so
06 you're not really following any of
this stuff oh seven oh my gosh someone's
going to be a black president this is
pretty amazing let me start look
following it and then you said
conversation with mom change your mind
you may want to see what
some of his values are yeah and i'm glad
she didn't direct me
she didn't say oh no you can't do this
or you or yes you can do this which i
think is a huge issue especially in the
black community but i think for a lot of
families period where parents just try
to say well you have to do this because
of this yeah and they don't give their
kids the opportunity to actually think
for themselves so when i researched and
found that out i tried to wake up as
many people as i could uh it was
bittersweet when he won and then it was
like okay round two 2012.
are we going to do this again
and we frickin did it again and it was
just like you know so you weren't a fan
of obama starting in 0.708 no can i ask
you you a question and then i want to
hear phil's opinion on this
you said last night being a black man
who's a conservative that a lot of your
family has alienated you right yes do
you mind if we discuss that no not at
all you talked about
the story where you stayed at the trump
hotel and your mom wouldn't go like
what's it like just being a conservative
black man your family's alienating you i
think 90 plus percent of african
americans vote for obama or approve
democrat like what's that like for for
guys like you
go ahead phil i mean i'll be honest like
going back to what you're saying from
last night you know competing at the
olympia i always wanted to stay at a
hotel where i had all the amenities that
i needed and it just happened to be the
trump hotel in las vegas that provided
that i didn't really think much of it
i'm kind of like david like i really
didn't even pay attention to politics
until obama came about at a dope hotel
that was yeah that's really what it was
but you know and his hotels are dope
yeah and they are yeah
yeah they're amazing i was always
treated with great amount of respect
receiving letters from the sun or you
know like hey because i'm there for 10
plus years
but anyway you know um i i really
noticed that
a lot of my family would not meet me
there
starting what year i probably from the
very beginning but i just didn't pay
attention like i said 2008. so from 2008
i was staying at the trump hotel right
and you know winning in the olympia in
2011 12 13 and so on um not much you
know
of them would come through so even even
free he could become an oppressor yeah
so like it was very interesting because
he was the the leading the birther cause
against obama i have no idea you know
but i remember
it had to be something she actually
started with hillary right trump didn't
start that birther mm-hmm
if she started it he certainly took it
and ran away oh no he ran with it so
definitely asking a simple question like
hey like why are you guys not coming
through and they're like you know your
mom hates trump and i'm like well what
the hell does that have to do with prior
to him running to president
like right before that okay and i'm like
well what the hell does that have to do
with your only son actually staying here
like for me it was just about like did
the person treat you wrong no okay at
the end of the day i looked at you know
from that on that day forward as
why are people just hating on this guy
you never met him
what policies are you disagreeing with
because i would you know love to be able
to have some understanding and for the
most part most of my family you know
they don't really talk about it
but uh when you talk about like force or
like you know pushing agendas that is
definitely you know a part of you know
family um
but i i'm always the type that has
always been in the middle i always just
want to vote like take the names off the
ballot let me look at the actual
policies
and just what do i identify with and
that's how i've always voted
very hard to do by the way we talk about
that a lot here but anyways to fast
forward to where david's at today i mean
if you follow david stuff on instagram
david's got millions of views millions i
don't even it's not even proper to say
millions of views probably hundreds of
millions online views is what david's
got he's all over the place
uh if you're not already following him
you may want to go follow him to see
what he's doing let's put the link below
for folks to be able to find him as well
let's get right into some topic let's
get right into some topics
a lot's happened we haven't been here
for about a week and a half because of
uh
last week's vault which was absolutely
sick
with dustin poitier we had uh what do
you call it uh gary casper who crushed
it by the way the message he had against
communism was fascinating and then we
had billy being there talking about data
we had a uh who else i'm forgetting phil
spoke friend uh greg shearer talking
about private equity crushed it
phil absolutely crushed it and then uh
uh
uh you know thank you
thousand people we had a nice party at
the yacht then afterwards we had a nice
party at the house couple nights ago you
know the place was uh uh unreal but the
most common conversation people were
there to find out how to take their
businesses to the next level right
that's right one of the most common uh
conversations that everybody was talking
about is how afraid they were about
freedom and capitalism so camera's off
there's no cameras we're talking at the
restaurant hey pat what do you think
about what's going to happen with
freedom what do you think what's gonna
happen with the capitalism what do you
think what's gonna happen these are
people from around the world that are
all having
the same types of conversations about uh
what we're gonna be doing but gary got
up
and gary delivered a message he called
that putin he called that he called out
everybody with no
restriction he didn't hold anything back
so he ran and await against putin here's
a
the goat of chess you're talking about a
guy that played chess for what he was
number one for 250 something months
in a row i've never heard of anybody
being number one
255 months in a row that's over 21 years
where you're think about all the goats
of all time who has ever been first
place for 255 months in poker in tennis
and basketball in baseball i've never
heard of anybody now the
credit to chess players you can't get a
knee injury it's not going to not going
to get you not you're not going right
your elbows out you know i got to get
some kind of a treatment but at the same
time the mental for
two to be able to stay that uh but i
love that question you asked him by the
way you said like you talk about you can
have a knee blow out but yeah you know
sports you know everything that's
happening with you but in chess how do
you get it it's all up here yeah he did
and his answer was look at at some point
after 20 years of being it doesn't
matter anymore you just get kind of
bored yeah it doesn't matter anymore i
thought it was interesting and then i
said so how politics and he aspirations
for politics he's like no i don't do
politics i don't do politics i was on
stage on stage so when we don't do
politics we had a good conversation in
the back would you share that
conversation uh the one in the back yeah
it was it was pretty i'll share a part
of it but i asked him i said what are
you doing he says what do you mean what
am i doing i said what are you doing i
said what was this all about he says i
don't understand the question i said you
have a message that the world needs to
hear about right you're a seven-year-old
kid in
russia
under a communistic regime that becomes
a phenom
the entire time you think america is the
worst country in the world then you get
a flavor of capitalism at 13 years old
then you realize how amazing capitalism
is then you come back and you win for
your country you have one of a few
people who was able to make it because
chess in russia is seen as
you know it's like uh uh there were
there yeah
now you got a message with all the mess
going on in the world then you want to
stay quiet he says well i tweet i i
write i said no that's not enough you
got to do something so he says what do
you think we should do anyways he sent
you an email which you guys are doing
something together in october yeah but
anyways it was uh it was good because
more and more you would be amazed how
many people around the world support
capitalism had a tweet that went out
today about the fact that um
you know why i love capitalism i said
here's a kid
uh uh
valuetainment put it up what was the
messaging let me see if i have it here
if you want to pull it up kai and then a
guy responds back and this is the one
messaging
that gets heat sometimes oh let me see
where this is kai if you pull it
up uh okay why i love capitalism it says
capitalism
allowed an immigrant like me with zero
generational wealth zero privileges and
a 1.8 gpa to my dreams become a reality
the only privilege i need was the fact
that my parents sacrificed everything to
bring us to u.s right the rest was on me
so then a guy responds back and he says
capitalism works
if you have capital to start off with
right if you have capital let's not be
able to read yeah exactly so this guy
responds back and he says capitalism
only works if you have capitalism to
start off with and i said not true
i started off with
zero no generational wealth that was a
99 cent store cashier mom went back to
iran because she ran out of money i
saved every penny i could have my jobs
instead of partying in order to one day
start a business others can do the same
there's this notion that
capitalism only benefits the rich
capitalism only benefits you know the
the few but at the end of the day it's
the greatest
economical system that allows anybody
with whatever skin color you have
whatever nationality whatever religion
we're at the event you're having all
these conversations
i cannot tell you how big of a muslim
population we had at the event yeah i
couldn't believe it a muslim capitalist
wow we're at the event our friend tamara
crying from stage emotional one girl got
up she was crying saying as a muslim
from azerbaijan i cannot wait she says
i'm willing to sacrifice my own life to
finish and end communism
this makes no sense there was one muslim
girl who mario-san says hey can i give
you a hug she says no i'm sorry we can't
do that she's that devout to her
religion right but supports capitalism
it doesn't matter what educational level
you were at what part of the world what
nationality it looked like the united
nations were there
except they were there to support
capitalism it was a beautiful thing to
see
one of our biggest audiences australia
they couldn't come out
one of our biggest we have italy that
was one of our biggest couldn't come out
germany so many different places
couldn't come out
there's a guy from germany that get
denied visa three times yeah and he got
in the fourth
he went to the embassy they told him no
he changed one guy he applied again one
guy flew from i don't know what it was
uh uh no no i don't know where it was
from he flew
he flew to one country then they sent
him back he flew to another country then
they send them back then he flew to
istanbul to try to go from istanbul to
central america to come to us in
istanbul they hold him back he's about
to get on the flight they send him back
he wasn't able to make the event three
different ways he tried to come out i
mean it's a mess right now around the
world what's going on we got obviously a
lot of stories to cover it's good to be
back
uh update on biz doc biz doc is doing
very good yeah he's making a lot of
progress i'm happy for him uh it was a
very positive news yesterday he was in
icu with pneumonia but he's doing better
shout out to ben yeah absolutely man
everybody that's been praying for
praying uh for him or meditating praying
or meditating sending positive thoughts
sending positive thoughts and vibes it's
been working but uh uh it's good to be
back having said that let me kind of go
through a couple stories with you and
we'll pick some of them we'll get into
them david i definitely want to take you
get your take on a couple things one is
hawaii
one is italy one is australia and
taliban because you've been very much uh
involved in uh spreading mess and i know
you're connected with a lot of guys that
are giving you stories on what's really
going on so we'll get into that here as
well so here's a few stories that we
have tech giants
are rushing to develop their own ships
here's why kai you may want to turn off
your mic
we'll talk about that story uh scotland
to try out a four-day work week latest
nation to attempt shift
disappointing august job report that
came back that threw a wrench and fed uh
taper plan which the numbers weren't
slightly off they were dramatically off
more americans are taking jobs without
employer benefits like health or paid
vacation we'll cover that here in a
minute california gas prices record
breaking on labor day weekend we'll talk
about the numbers there tim tim tebow
joining espn's first take as new stephen
a smith's foe
adam sandler says netflix asked him to
rewrite his new movie so it wasn't set
in china because the company doesn't do
business in china taliban declares china
as their closest ally taliban angry and
disappointed after u.s disabled military
equipment before leaving kabul
trump reportedly often hates ron
desantis we're going to ask david to see
if he's ever heard anything like this
before melania trump is telling friends
that she has no interest in being the
first lady despite her husband's 2024
teases report says and texas can openly
carry guns in public without a permit or
training police say the new law makes it
harder to do their jobs having said that
let's first get into gas prices with
california
because california just loves paying
high gas prices let's give a little
shout out here with what happened with
gas prices okay
california's will pay highest labor day
weekend gas prices ever fox business
story drivers in california will pay
more than labor day weekend for gasoline
than they have ever in the past for the
first time of year according to numbers
from automobile club of california the
current 439
4.39
per gallon price of regular gas is
california's new record high for labor
day weekend up from 323 a year ago the
current national average is 3 18
and california is 439 the prior highs
per regular on liberty weekend was in
2012 when it was 416. the average price
of gas in u.s has continued to climb
since the beginning of last year in
deadly hurricane isa hitting the
critical refinery areas of the gulf
coast in recent days sparked concerns
that shortages could drive gas prices
even higher fy the record-breaking day
for california ever for gas prices was
october of 2012
seventy cents what are your thoughts on
gas prices in california adam i'll go to
you first well how by the way how do you
remember that it was october of twenty i
looked at it yeah yeah i looked it up
okay gotcha i don't know when you were
living in california october 2012 i'm in
california look i think
it's sort of a combination of a few
things it's sort of the perfect storm
not to use the the ida
uh analogy there but
obviously the the hurricane hitting um
the refineries doesn't help
i think notoriously the end of summer
labor day this is your last vacation
people are trying to hit the streets
people are trying to get out of there
supply
supply and demand people clearly want to
go hit the road and then obviously you
gotta look at inflation and say all
right like
is this here is this gonna is this
leaving i think it's just sort of the
perfect storm
and the the beautiful thing like in
capitalism you have a choice you don't
have to take that cross-country trip you
can stay home obviously a lot of people
in california thank you caroline
don't have to necessarily leave their
houses but
that's the beautiful thing if you don't
want to deal with these ridiculous
prices don't take a long road trip if
paying a buck or two extra
i mean what is that going to come out to
another 50 100 bucks on your trip is
really something you're not worried
about take your trip but obviously
nobody loves paying high prices for gas
but supply and demand it is what it is
but you live in california right you
lived in california i lived in
california we're used to these
ridiculous prices no well yeah they
always seem to go up around holidays
like labor day uh fourth of july anytime
that people are traveling a bunch
but uh you know the thing with
california is
everything is so high the cost of living
is so high um that i think their their
economy is like could be the third you
know largest country in the world just
based out of california and what's how
much money goes through there and uh
and the country is just going to go in
the toilet i mean there's so much
homelessness
and they continue
again it's like everything doesn't have
to be political but when you continue to
elect the people that are pushing for
and allowing things like uh you know the
woman that got shot killed by the
illegal oh well he's not guilty and but
people can go in now and they can rob
less than a thousand dollars from the
store and literally just walk out of the
store and the cops aren't gonna get get
called on them uh and you can take a
crap on the street that's okay too but
don't you dare use a plastic straw
and then you look at how the state's
been ran by gavin nussolini uh who's had
absolute lockdown right on businesses
when uh all throughout the whole entire
state you've got people that aren't
working people that can't go to work
families that own businesses that can't
open their doors
and then you want to add high gas prices
on top of it so the perfect storm to me
is is
not only what is taking place with the
gas line with hurricane ida all that
stuff does does play a part but for
california as a whole they need new
leadership over there you know they need
somebody that's actually going to say
okay wait a minute we need to make some
changes in how we're going to enact
these policies
we need to start focus on things that
are going to actually help californians
and the main thing that's going to help
california is allowing them to go to
work allowing them to open up their
businesses
uh if you you know california's probably
the closest state in new york is the
closest state to what we're seeing take
place in australia right now where i
post on my instagram on my way in here
today they're literally talking about a
system and implementing a system in
australia where you can't go and buy or
sell anything unless you've gotten the
jab they're he's literally talking about
they want a vaccinated society in
australia he's like we're not there yet
because we still have people that you
know we still have open dates for you
can get jet you can get the jab uh but
if you want to get this vaccine you're
gonna have to get it because we're gonna
shut it down it's like that's happening
do you think there's some dark forces at
work that are purposely driving up the
gas prices so californians aren't
running around town and doing that or is
it just actually because it's labor day
ida is there is there is there a hidden
back story or is it because it is what
it is with supplies
i think i think it is what it is i'm not
sure you know i mean
we're in a spiritual battle all the time
but he's not an action spiritual guy
yeah he's never been a conspiracy guy
what are you starting a conspiracy here
you're sitting there go ahead david
you've got to be careful with this guy
i like that that's it maybe caroline put
something else in there but please go
ahead so
so they just they need to do leadership
you know hopefully they'll get it
hopefully they'll actually get a fair
election uh on this recall with uh do
you think he's got a chance
i think larry older has a chance yeah if
the if the election is actually uh
credible i mean did you read that
article by l.a times about larry elder
what yeah the one calling him a racist
white supremacist white supremacist yeah
yeah
larry
there's an article calling him
a white supremacist that's when you know
you're a threat is that an article from
the onion no no no no no okay you know
what they did first pull up the price
you know what they did you know what
this reminds me of you just took trump's
name off of it but larry in there click
on regular yeah you've seen the chapel
skit with the clayton bigsby
where he's the kkk black black
that's what they're trying to pull on
larry elder to the right of alaska you
see where it says go to alaska no right
there on the list gas prices bottom
bottom kai bottom oh my god
on this and it's going to do ranking by
the highest
holy moly okay get that a little higher
look this this is the biggest concern
though if you think about it
i understand if gas prices between a
heist and a bottom one is 30 cents maybe
even 45 cents california is officially
higher than hawaii how the hell is gas
prices in california higher than hawaii
so california is 439 okay
premium you're paying 471 by the way
diesel's 438
then that go and that's average in the
state that's average in the state that's
some beat some parts of the some parts
of the state are seeing five and six
dollars in gas that's right isn't
california more than anyone pushing
electric vehicles is that's part part of
it well of course yeah they are and
we'll talk about the chip shortage but
so california you got 439 then you got
hawaii and nevada washington utah idaho
oregon alaska 366 wyoming illinois 333
montana new york new york is 320. how
the hell is new york 328 in california
is 439.
how is that even these are both ran by
similar type of politics how the hell is
california a dollar a dollar higher than
new york and new york just got hit with
ida and new york is the one that got hit
without anatomy california okay where's
even dc is 320. keep going lower
arizona's 314. north dakota is 360 adam
if you're thinking about it north dakota
may not be a bad moment for you keep
going up keep going up ohio 328 florida
three uh
three dollars and a penny okay
uh iowa's the first one that breaks the
two dollar mark keep going lower
keep going lower tennessee 290
texas is going to be the second to the
bottom i think yeah texas 280
mississippi 279. wow that's why you're
in texas so break this all down what do
you think is happening well first of all
states have
the ability to add their own individual
taxes which is what newsome did like tax
newsome added an additional gas tax 25
cents 15 cents 13 cents suck it's not a
big deal no one's going to pay no one's
going to notice it it's just a 25 cent
hike so california has some of the most
gas tax on top of everybody else that
they add to you you're saying california
is kind of gassy
it is kind of gassy only you would think
of it but that's great that's our friend
who called you out well this is what
happens when you spend a lot of time
with kids last night you know there was
a lot of kids you're getting them to
dress up a little bit that was not me
first of all then you bring them up and
that was not me you don't pin that on me
that's don't you pin this on me
on you for the rest of your life oh i
went and adam said
dylan said adam asked me to dress up to
come to you
and i said adam's gonna be in trouble
for this one anyways
so the biggest conversation with this
again dude i don't mind if gas if you
tell me
you're in
alaska and you say look you're in hawaii
we don't have access to gas it has to go
from here to here to here to here to
here fine little bit of argument you're
california you're not new york you're a
buck higher than new york you're bucked
and hired in dc what is your argument
california keeps constantly hurting
themselves if there's ever been a time
for the state of california to be
willing to try another way of thinking
and leading like an elder or anybody
else this may be the time to do it and
by the way this guy actually stands a
chance and why not make history
first black governor of california ever
while l.a times will say first black
white
supremacist governor can you pull up
that uh article about uh it's disgusting
you know it is disgusting no question
about it they're using this playbook
like that's the hard part but but i got
it hopefully that's waking people up too
no to see that wait a minute you're now
calling a black guy that's been in
california most of his life on the radio
for 30 years trying to wake people up
you're now calling him a white
supremacist kai you see the first one
like i don't understand what you're
doing you just click down it says white
supremacy go to the next one
kyle listen kai's defense he woke up he
was breakfast he woke up late today he's
david i'm saying no
today kai is kai everything okay you
work too hard at the vault like what was
he dead he did look
okay
l.a time story larry larry elders fans
prove he's a face of white supremacy
okay
you think somebody's gotta buy l.a times
maybe to just kind of uh shift their way
of thinking a little bit anyway so
california
just as two
you know black men
how do you register that a black man
being the face
of white supremacy in california how do
you process this ignorance and bigotry
thank you
it's like they're you know it's it's the
bigot it's the racist that is going to
throw out the race card as somebody
that's that a has
nothing whatsoever to do with the entire
mantra the entire phrase the ideology of
what a white supremacist is
um
and and b is uh
just you know just doesn't care what
people think it's like they're
publishing this of national paper right
the la times publishing a story to their
to their readers tells you that they
believe that they've got enough of a
stranglehold programming right like tv's
programming enough of a programming
mechanism on their readers to believe so
well some of them won't believe it let's
just go ahead and run with it and the
other thing it does it completely
dilutes what it would mean to be a white
supremacist it's like they they want to
take the worst possible thing it's like
calling somebody hitler you know saying
they're they're they're nazi uh they
want to take the worst possible thing
and label somebody that to hope that
there's a shock reaction do you think
there's a remote do you think that
unfortunately
unfortunately it does for some folks
because they're so programmed they don't
know any difference you know you know
what i think that does though let me
tell you what this is my opinion i may
be completely and then i think some
people it wakes them up but go ahead
yeah i think i think to me
like you you ever had somebody that was
older than you or whatever they tried to
kind of uh uh uh
impose a certain mindset on you to
divide you against a relative or
somebody that you knew well you know
that person yeah and they try to say
something that's the thing you know well
right but what i'm saying is even if
somebody tries to patronize me
and i'm somebody that questions
everything that article pisses me off
even if i don't follow politics an
article like that gets me to say what
the hell are you talking about but how
many are free thinkers at this point i
think more than you think because i
think by the way it's not the majority
that's for sure but i do think that 10
20 is more than you think and it doesn't
take look at the end of the day how many
people does it take to change the
generational curse of any family how
many how many one person right it
doesn't take 50 not 100 so if your
family's filled with alcoholics one guy
says boom i'm done i'm not doing it
anymore we're not alcoholics in this
family well your dad drank your
grandfather drank your uncle's drink i'm
not doing it cocaine drugs alcohol
whatever it is somebody eventually says
what i'm you're poor you're broke this
entire family everybody says we're poor
we're poor we're poor one person says
done and then all the other kids or
nephews nieces says one day i want to be
like that uncle one day i want to be
like that auntie one day i want to be
like that person it takes one person
articles like that i believe
wakes up people who were never involved
in the first place and then they say
dude you know what i'm getting the
freaking ring what the hell are you
talking about yeah and then they get
pissed off that's what i bid on that's
what i hope happens more than anything i
think there's more free thinkers than we
think by the way a good-looking guy
named gerard michaels just gave 20 bucks
what a sweetheart what is sweetheart
god bless you god bless you
i have a feeling we'll see him later
today don't you think i have a feeling
we will get anyways real quick rogan de
la hoya okay what's going on there i
know that's the story you wanted me to
cover
so rogan de la hoya
uh both get covered okay yeah okay
de la hoya gets coveted he's vaccinated
he's in the hospital talking about he
doesn't feel good he can't hardly talk
can hardly talk he's like yeah and he
had a fight come up yeah and he posts a
video on instagram i think
rogan gets colvid he openly talks about
it i don't feel good i don't do this
three days later after he tested
positive he tests negative because he
said we took the entire what is a
kitchen
the horse uh
tranquilizer that's what the mainstream
media is trying to label it yeah
whatever i'm just saying this is what
you just said
has been used for
years
in this country for americans for people
for humans
but just like for drugs for humans
they've got stuff for dogs they've got
stuff for horses and everything else but
what he's here's the biggest thing
this is the biggest thing the biggest
thing is
uh uh with the fact that the guy uh my
household there's a bunch of people that
have in the house i'm living in bunch of
you that have taken a vaccine some that
don't want to take it
so for us it's not like hey you want to
take it i'm going to take oh cool go
take it someone's like i'm not going to
take it but i'm going to take it
eventually okay great so i'm saying i'm
just not going to take it i don't think
i need it fine
whatever your position is with the
vaccine right there's audience that's
pissed off that rogan found a way to fix
himself and heal himself without any how
crazy you know remedies why why that's
the part that confuses me the most if
somebody figures out a way to get
themselves now here's the thing
when covet first came about there was a
couple different camps one was what it's
fake one was what it's real okay we all
learn very quickly it's not fake if you
had covet it sucks you had it i had it i
don't know if you have you've had it or
not you said you may have had it i don't
even know about it yeah i think you had
it you ended up having it right right
after some event or something that took
place
okay are you open talking about when
that was when you got it or not it was
right after sheree okay so yeah but it
was right after a show right yeah okay
so
so you have you have covet when you had
it symptoms what happens for me i lost
20 plus pounds it sucked i flat out lost
20 pounds
taste didn't do anything to me with
taste uh breathing didn't do anything to
me with br i just couldn't eat for you
you lost you lost the smell
it's actually not a bad thing if you
think about it for like who's got onions
garlic who's got onions
if there's somebody's gadget it smells
like somebody's in the office just so
you know mussolini over here none of us
have said anything before six months you
smell terrible
that story you tell about with the hairy
guy
we just
they won the first date it's because
they could smell you couldn't smell
anyways adam's one of the cleanest guys
you made in your life by the way so you
had yours as well what was your symptoms
when you i didn't even know okay so but
but for some like right now i know a lot
of friends that are not doing well i had
a couple conversations with them last
night one is in the icu
two of them were in the icu a couple of
them are going through covet and it
absolutely sucks right okay now uh you
ever had bronchitis before oh yeah how
bad is it
terrible yeah it's not funny i mean
what's the worst thing you've ever had
in your life that you thought you could
die what's the worst thing you've ever
had have you had anything where you're
like dude this sucks
like you was not self-induced
david harris jr
truth comes out
yeah that's another story but almost
overdosing is a
reality how bad of a situation is that
oh yeah i thought i was gonna die
i actually should have died wow how old
are you at that point
um
it was 11 years ago so 35 wow
and would you share that's what were you
doing what was it by the way he he said
it so subtly 11 years ago i was 35
meaning today you're how old 46. i would
have never freaking guess this guy's 46.
no seriously
i wouldn't ever guess he's four even
jennifer yesterday thought i thought
you're in your late 20s
[Laughter]
not jennifer your wife jennifer my wife
yes so you're both jennifer's okay and
david's
so you want to you want to
tell him because he asked you a question
yeah we can we can dive into that um
i'll just summarize you know uh
not walking with the lord trying to do
my things my own way
the you know my go-to's were alcohol and
then when your party starts to get a
little bit long it's coke and it keeps
the party going
and uh so i had been that had been doing
that we were living in southern
california orange county and uh a friend
of mine that uh
we would we would party together
we went out to go get some uh coke this
one night
and we got it and it wouldn't chop up
and i know this is not just r-rated
right but everybody's seen the movies at
least you know cocaine chops up it's
powder it wouldn't chop up
and it was just kind of mushy
and he said well let's just smoke it
and so we smoked it and it was unlike
anything i'd ever tried before
and then uh and then he's all how you
like that and i was like oh that was
different and he's all i was i believe
that's freebasing it was crack yeah yeah
okay so that started about almost two
years
where i kept it from my wife brother for
the most part but i lost about 50 pounds
i continued to lose you're a big dude
what 65
yeah six four 250 255.
um and you went down to what 180
okay my high school weight
so my wife didn't know what was going on
she uh we moved back to reading you were
doing this without her knowledge
whatever yeah i was doing it at night
um and uh or just i was i was working on
road crews a lot so we'd leave for a
week or two
so we moved back to reading and within
like a month she just knew something was
wrong i found a new friend misery loves
company right i found a new friend i
used to do coke with and told him i was
doing crack and he's like i want to try
it i was like that's a first somebody's
like want to try crack i would have
never said sure give me some crack until
my buddy's just like here smoke it so um
that uh
my wife moved out took the kids
and she's like i don't know what's going
on but i know it's not right and we
would just be up like all night into the
wee hours in the morning four or five
hours consumed your life is what you're
saying oh yeah well i would still go to
work i would try to go to work during
the day
which was my business life was just
falling apart i was a business business
owner at the time and you're in your
mid-30s at this point it's not like you
were some kids and a college kid you
were a grown-ass man with a family man
yeah yeah wow
so my wife reached out to an old friend
of ours and said jeff you've got to talk
to david
jeff we've known for he's one of my
oldest and dearest friends a strong
believer when i went and met with him uh
he later told me he said you know that
king in lord of the rings that had the
spirit of death on him
he's like that looked like you
he's like i could see death on you
this was later i'll get to what happened
so we had that talk and then
one night i was with my friend uh that
we were just staying up and playing
games and smoking and you're not
supposed to you're not supposed to
you're supposed to exhale pretty quick
once you hit it and you try to i'm
always trying to push the envelope and i
inhale it and kept it in a little bit a
little too long i guess and my eyeball
started going up and down like that fast
like you can't make your eyeballs go up
and down that fast
and in that moment
i know i heard god's voice just saying
don't freak out
this will pass
this will pass and so i didn't look at
my friend sitting across the table
because i knew he'd freak out
like i would freak out if i saw
somebody's eyeballs doing that right
yeah it lasted about 60 seconds
and then it just subsided went away
so the next morning i called the friend
that introduced me to crack and told him
what happened
and he said david if you would have
freaked out and panicked your heart
would have exploded your body was
overdosing
so it was about two weeks later
if you can believe that but it was about
two weeks later that i had finished
doing all the drugs i had which was
fronted to me actually
i finished it all and then it was
saturday night i was done
and i just said god i made an absolute
mess of my life
my wife's gone
business is shut down what do you want
me to do
and i heard him say go to church
and this is now sunday morning i'm
having this argument so to speak with
god
and i finally stopped arguing it was
like i had nothing i was absolutely just
just destitute and uh broke
so i stopped arguing with god
i went to church it's a large large
church in reading called bethel church
and that was a church i used to go to um
i share that just to say it's very large
and the road that leads to the church is
like one road and it only goes to the
church so i got in the car i turned on
caleb
i think that's what the guy was
listening to on my uber on the way here
actually today i'm listening to caleb
and i just started weeping i just
started bawling i was just like i'm just
broken so broken
i drive the cars are lining the side of
the street that the church is so packed
i get to the church i get to the top
cars everywhere
and then i in the i see a sign that says
parking lot full and i keep driving and
the very first parking spots open so i
park
i walk inside they had the overflow was
just packed in the lobby and the church
was totally packed service was probably
just done with worship so it's probably
going for an hour
i look in the auditorium and
no seats anywhere and i get a tap on my
shoulder this lady's like you're looking
for a seat you can have mine i'm right
in the middle third row from the left on
the left
so i'm kind of like looking up like okay
i got a seat i got this parking spot i
go and i sit down as soon as i sit down
the pastor comes walking out and he says
today's message i'm going to talk to you
about the prodigal son coming home
and walking into his inheritance talk
about timing
total total god thing right total papa
thing so i hear the message i talked to
a couple pastors that i knew that were
right there chris valatin and a couple
others told them what i was dealing with
cracked told them almost ode
and
chris actually prayed for me and it felt
like his hand just sunk into my my sunk
into me
and um never the same after that never
touched crack cocaine again and then
cold turkey boom you're done turkey
after one 11 years yeah well 11 years
ago yeah i was doing it for two years
have you touched alcohol since anything
since yeah yeah i still dab a little bit
of alcohol quit that about three years
ago
um and then my wife and i quit together
which has been amazing almost a year ago
so that's been a strong thing because it
was hard
being married at least for us we were
kind of codependent we got married young
right i was 18 she was 16. that's a
whole other story
but we grew up together and then having
issues
it can be easy to just you know she's
doing it i'm doing it we'll both do it
although she never did crack we used to
do other stuff together
but um
so god is good man he just his mercy is
real his forgiveness is real his
restoration is real i wouldn't be here
today if it wasn't for him
and uh now i've got this platform so
anyway that's it's crazy the stories
last couple weeks by the way right i
mean it's not even intentional just kind
of goes
into it the last two podcasts yep right
even the pascal podcast with jared and
jarrah's not even a uh
believer there are just you know there's
a guy who's gerard story is insane
his story about how he got stabbed and
how he doesn't drink hard liquor anymore
and gerard's got any kind of gotta get
to the lowest point to
redeem yourself thank you for sharing
that brother i appreciate you a lot of
commentary here is blown over by the
story adam what's the worst
uh uh health condition you ever had
where you're like dude this is this is
nothing comes close to this this sucks
yeah well luckily i've never had
anything like that before uh i have
partied my ass off in south beach but
i've always known my limits so i've
never been into the powder been more
into the uh
the green at the end of the night you
know like money
yeah the money i spent money
money's grown on trees so luckily i've
never had these issues i've never had
this fall from grace or these
you know major uh hills and valleys i
think i
the worst
yeah i've had covet was pretty bad
for three days i could not move i just
glued to my bed and then i think i think
i had the
a bad flu one time before but luckily
i've been blessed with good health phil
flu shot flu shot 20 years old
because because uh you know playing
division one basketball they wanted
everybody to take the flu shot and i was
like man i don't really want to do this
but at 19 you know freshman year i took
it i didn't feel so good then
and then sophomore year comes around and
i'm like like really bad
for like
10 days
so i had to go to like the uh
you know they on campus they have like a
medical facility and this and that and
they're like we got to run some tests
because
you can't leave
you got sick from the flu shot yeah at
20. so this is 20 plus years ago
yeah and they came back and we're like
uh you have a certain gene variant that
like depending on certain uh flu vaccine
or whatever it could really uh create
some problems for you so i remember
telling the the team doc i'm like i'm
not taking that ever again i was at 21.
you're like well i guess you're not
gonna play i was like i don't give it
you know i don't care it was that bad
yeah like you know like two days of like
knowing that like you got to run tests
on me
and i just felt like um to be honest i
mean like i just felt like ncaa they
didn't give a damn you know the coaching
staff they didn't care they're like oh
well
you got to get it because it protects
everybody else and this and that we're
all you know traveling together this
night and i'm like but
i almost died so like screw you like i
don't miss a couple games i don't care
so right so that was your close call
yeah how about yours pat dude
health and maybe you you know in the
army you used to party i'm not going to
count that stuff that stuff is just this
stuff is the
life self-inflicted you know some of
that stuff is self-inflicted but even
but i would say forget the war in iran
i'm talking health like health as a
situation like something happens you
catch bronchitis or pollen all that all
the drink and all the stuff that i did
it's just you know in the army you drink
to kill a
one or two bottles of tequila every week
for two years straight so just think
about that yeah so if you noticed if you
notice the stock of jose cueva doing
good from 97.99
thanks pb they owe you some money
[Laughter]
and i was a great recruiter as well yes
i never dreamed alone yeah and i said
guys come on hey guys
big meeting big meeting huddle up it's
our monday motivation
by the way one of these days felix and
bradford's got to tell these stories of
how it was in the army anyway so for me
yeah i had bronchitis sucked right
pneumonia just in the last 15 years i
had it it sucked in the army i had a
dehydration situation which was terrible
because i was digging a foxhole and i
was trying to be such a
you know a great soldier that i dug up
six foxholes six feet by three feet by
six feet
in cat 4 cat 5 in
you know south carolina in the heat in
july august which is the worst time to
do so got completely dehydrated wasn't a
hospital they had ivs on me left and
right so i've had a lot of those
instances where i pushed the envelope
but allergy would pollen believe it or
not yeah i was in the emergency room for
like straight
13 times in a span of two weeks uh
the first six months of 2019.
right now i can't breathe damn i just
couldn't breathe two years ago yeah
that's two years ago obviously i didn't
announce it i said i don't i don't
but it was kicking my
ass i thought it's over with right i
thought i'm like jen jim would hold my
hands i'm like i can't breathe jen so we
go straight to your middle of the night
one o'clock two o'clock in the morning
right pollen and i asked the doctor so
where should i live the doctor said you
should be as close to the ocean as
possible that's all you have to say
right all right
hey i'm gonna be such a house in front
of the water because the doctor said so
right now
what about the story you talked about
when you were doing the php tour and you
oh yeah
but that was because i was just pushing
sometimes i don't mind those exhaustion
from working toward i don't mind those
because those happen once every other
year once every three years i get one of
those right just go in and a doctor says
your body is just telling you you got to
shut it down for a couple days you get a
few ivs you come out sleep sleep sleep
underrated underrated yeah underrated
sleep once a week i tell you i need a
good once a week to get it anyways the
point is this the point is the best news
we're getting is the following
is
that both people are figuring out a way
to fight this thing which is great and
we're learning if there's ever been a
time in your life
where the need to want to lose weight
and be in shape
has been the reason to do so if there's
ever been a time you know people say hey
uncle johnny take care of yourself hey
babe take care of yourself hey bro you
got to kind of lose some hey dude you
got to kind of like if there's ever been
a time where you got to take your weight
seriously today's the time by the way
yeah you know what's crazy this message
when you give this message
you know who hears it
no no the people that need to hear it
they're like can we change the topic
already or something else bro this is
like i'm telling you you're doing it
they're like yes exactly like i'm 42
years old phil and we were talking about
it yesterday you were telling me all
this stuff flexibility i'm feeling at 42
right i'm training with my guy he says
listen if you don't start at 42 exercise
and this thing gets very hard at 50. and
it's going to get harder and harder and
harder health exercise is very important
covet validated clean your hands you
know that's one thing fine the other
part is your diet your health absolutely
you got you got to go take your health a
lot of people just don't look at that so
but you know joe rogan pounding more
power to him so happy for the guy very
happy if he's very very necessary today
for the world this is not even like
joe's necessary for the states joe is
necessary for the world because he's
getting everybody
to have the tough conversations so glad
the guy is doing good three days after
having covered yeah yeah actually what
does mancia say about him by the way
carlos mancia said great uh he said what
i uh uh he says what he said i got covet
uh uh he says now they're gonna say yeah
what was the tweet about him you sent it
to me it was hilarious you stole covid
from rogan
yeah that's he got or something like
first of all carlos gotta get on joe
rogan and get it over with by the way
carlos gomez needs to come on this show
he already has oh you've been coming
back on the podcast yeah we're trying to
get a date for him to come on the show
come on carlos you will no but you're
definitely right i mean joe rogan like
shout out to you i mean you know at the
end of the day we really just have to
take the aesthetics out of like working
out and just look at just the health in
it in itself i think when people talk
about you know health they're like oh
well you're talking about a slim waist
and this and that it's like well yeah
but
we're really like at the vault i was
talking about how all these
entrepreneurs you know they want to work
hard hard hard push push push to make
money for their families god bless them
but at what cost
right you know so then when they get
older they're trying to buy back their
health yeah it's a very powerful message
let's try to figure out a balance but
most importantly right now like with
past saying i mean we're at a great
moment in time where we should be
outside vitamin d we should be getting
healthier you know foods in our bodies
you only get one body
you should really treat it with greater
amount of respect
and this isn't fat shaming or anything
like that but obesity does kill yeah and
right now with kovid we it the stats
show
that if you are overweight you need to
do something about that now that may
come at a you know a price later on if
you ignore it or you could pay for it
now and hire personal trainer you can or
you can go on google and start figuring
out
you know what healthy methods can i do
currently there's so much information
out there so i just want to encourage
more people to
you know just like how you would treat
your business treat your body even
better
you know really mind that body like
figure out like
what you think you're eating probably
isn't healthy well let's change that you
know fast food probably not you know
let's let's learn how to cook again
let's let's learn how to maybe drink
less alcohol
get proper sleep and when we talk about
recharging our bodies let's recharge
them so then when we are going back like
when you say you know you're going to
run yourself hard hard hard but then you
know how to recharge so you can do it
again majority of people don't know how
to do that so question for you phil
heath seven time mr olympia
how lucky are we
if there's a scale 100 what percentage
of
health and wellness is attributed to
diet versus exercise of working out can
you give those this is very very
interesting because at the vault i had
people tell me what it was
they're like oh it's just uh eighty
percent diet twenty percent working out
and they say well if that's the case
then
there would be no gyms like you know you
have to move your body is it 50 50 what
are you saying i mean i think it
definitely depends i would say for the
most part people got to start moving
their bodies so i'm going to go probably
60 40. 64. i'm going to say 40. no 40
i'm going to say moving your body 60
diet 40. oh wow uh because just you know
in the in the bodybuilding world that's
very unconventional to say that that
that's what's that's what he's saying
here because most people will say the 80
20 rule right
they move your body it's very very you
have to do it like how many people are
actually getting 30 to 45 minutes of
cardiovascular work three to four times
a week just cardio in itself
very few people
how many people are eating like crap all
the time every freaking day so you
definitely have to move your body you
know it you know it enhances your
lymphatic drainage we talk about the
lymphatic system we can go into that in
another time but just the levels of
inflammation and due to covid there's
this thing called covid
fatigue
so you know people stressed out all the
time their cortisol levels going through
the roof the inflammation that they
carry you know you start seeing people
that stress you look at their eyes and
you look at their cheeks
you know like they they just look run
down well because they're on the
internet looking at negative stuff so we
talk about positivity more we talk about
loving ourselves more thanking ourselves
more for even standing up for you know
the adverse times
but uh you know i really do believe like
when you talk about uh faith i think
it's very important that we find
something very positive that we could
you know look at to hold us up when we
can't hold ourselves up
awesome so good conversation here uh
let's move on to the next story which is
the tim tebow joining espn's first take
as new steven a smith's foe
uh i have some feedback on this i'm
curious to know what you're going to say
about the steam tebow we'll be joining
espn's first take as one of steven a
smith's for the network announced
thursday the mid-mannered bible toting
tebow will prove an intriguing foil to
smith whose honor outbursts have made
him the face of espn and in turn given
autonomy over the makeup of the daily tv
show the 34 year old tiba has worked for
espn as a college football analyst in
the past and is coming off a failed nfl
comeback attempt this summer thibault
tried to convert from a quarterback to a
tied in with jacksonville under his
former college head coach urban meyer
but was cut before the season he
previously told in the mets minor league
system for five years this guy just
wants to compete he's like saying dude
put me in the game uh uh put me put me
in coach i wanna
uh i'm ready to play right this guy
wants to compete so espn
getting tim tebow fridays is going to be
tim tebow mondays is going to be michael
irvin and then tuesday through thursday
they're going to mix it up okay michael
irvin and stephen when they're together
it does very well right
obviously back in the days this thing
blew up when it was skipped bayless yes
versus stephen h it was popping yes max
good on the football side he's done good
with uh uh you know his uh analysis how
do you think this is going to work out
with tim tebow being on first take i'm
going to go to you first
uh
look
i think
in terms of stephen a smith versus tim
tebow if those are the two
contenders
i think tebow is completely out of his
league i think in what sport though
anything and everything except for
football okay good and look what's
steven a's first sport though basketball
okay okay so what let me ask you who
knows more about baseball
tebow or steve but it's for for me i
don't even know if it's the knowledge of
the sport
it's the ability to talk and use your
words and then just get out there and
like make yourself heard and then use
all these words and these analogies
don't underestimate but i'm saying
there's a stake in the sizzle yeah i
don't think he got the sizzle he might
have the steak yeah i don't think he's
going to bring the heat to steve you've
never seen him call people out you never
saw him give that one message i got like
50 million views when he called out the
team saying what the hell happened today
like he grilled their entire i hear you
i hear you i don't think he's a
lightweight but i don't think he's on
stephen on a serious note are you
lobbying for you getting the job i mean
i could think i could hang i'm stephen a
smith i'd love to give it a shot okay
but i do have respect for tebow i met
tebow
uh obviously more than anything i think
a good influence on the culture yeah or
as my friend uh gerard likes to use i'm
the zeitgeist but i think he's a great
dude i think he's got a good message i
think from a debate standpoint i think
stephen a smith's gonna run all over
them how much you follow sports are you
one that follows first take all that or
not really no i don't i stopped watching
um football specifically and and then
all of them when they all followed suit
and started doing the whole blm thing
kneeling for the answer you literally
stopped oh i literally were you a sports
guy did you play your six four you know
i was a dancer
oh my goodness that was a dude
my choreographer danced with michael
dance with janet who danced with paula
wow really uh yeah he was he was these
[Laughter]
i did some popping and stuff but but
eric henderson was he was he was in
michael jackson's uh captain neo he was
in several of janet jackson's uh uh
videos
and um
he was the it guy he was actually so
good that when he was dancing on a set
like a big open it was actually outside
madonna was walking up and down the
aisle looking at dancers and picking
them out she looked at him and she's all
he's too good she didn't want him on
this on the stage with her but he was
phenomenal and so
yeah i just i danced early i was in a
never played football i could see your
high school background
church i did trying to recruit you like
crazy when we got into high school it
was either running around and get sweaty
with a bunch of guys
or dance with all the girls me and phil
so i'm like i'm like i'm i'm dancing and
hey god use that because my girlfriend
uh well jennifer my bride now but my
girlfriend before i met her in high
school
we were in a we were in a rally the
whole high school was in the gym like
the whole high school so it's a rally
right
and uh i was in the competition group
and it was just i was the only guy
because most guys can't dance especially
in high school they can't dance and keep
up with the girls so there's eight girls
behind me this way and eight girls
behind me this way
we're in a v formation we're tearing it
up we actually learned the numbers uh
the dance routine they just done on soul
train music awards so jennifer before i
ever met her
she sees me dancing she nudges her best
friend and she's like i'm going to marry
that guy wow before whatever dancing
there you go see that's never happened
you still want to dance
let's circle back to the mid 90s i was
killing bar mitzvah dance floors all
right you don't want no part
okay let's get back to tim tebow here so
here's another experiment there's a
question you got to think about with tim
tebow and uh by the way if you're
listening to this if you think tim can
hang with steven a and you think this is
a good move smash thumbs up
if you say no this is not going to work
put thumbs down if you think it's going
to work thumbs up if you don't think
it's going to work put thumbs down
this is my biggest concern this is my
biggest concern with
this my biggest concern with this taking
place for for uh first take
i don't know if espn
as a company
will keep a conservative on
history says no okay history says no
because if you think about what happened
with will kane i thought wilkin was
great
i liked him a lot yeah but will kane
started kind of talking about i remember
you don't remember him if you pull up
will kanye
wilkins guy was an absolute start of a
guy i loved him debating and he made
some good uh good arguments
cain i know dean cain that's right you
know who he is you know who type in
images you know who he is will king okay
yeah
didn't agree with all of them but half
the time i'm like okay he's pushing the
envelope you know whether it was
kaepernick whether it was some of these
things okay i don't know if espn wants
opposing arguments on those types of
issues they fired him he went to fox
okay they didn't keep him there he went
to fox espn doesn't keep conservative
hosts and if they do
if they keep team tim tebow i think it's
a very good business move not
philosophical move because they're gonna
be able to regain some audiences that
they lost over the last five years
you gotta convert yeah but i don't know
if espn's gonna by the way kudos to espn
for giving tim tebow the once a week
kudos for espn more power to you now
let's see if he can he's going to keep
his job no i think it's i think it's
smart for espn to have uh tim tebow on i
think it's very important because he is
college football
you know he could talk about football
non-stop but like you talk about
him going back and forth with steven hey
what stephen a can't talk about is the
mental fortitude of commanding team
commanding other men
in order to go on the field and do
amazing things stephen a has not done
that right so i i definitely feel like
tim tebow can say you know hey man in
the arena
you're over here stephen a i was
actually in those rooms i was actually
on that field it's a lot of like it's a
little it's a little bit different and
with his age even though oh he you know
he doesn't know how to do this he
doesn't want to do that he's like hey
stephen a you're making a lot of money
with espn but i was out there on the
field learning talk about the humility
of me going from heisman to this this
this i have no quit in me so you don't
think that tim tebow's going to say i
have no quit in me what makes you think
that i'm not going to outlast you what
makes you think i'm not going to come
back bigger and better and stronger and
faster smarter
that's what i'm honestly expecting from
him i hope he crushes it
by the way i liked max kellerman were
you a max guy i was not a max guy really
i was not a max guy yeah
because max tried too hard to be black
whoa that's it because max tried so hard
to be black what does that mean are you
kidding me did you ever wa like he was
he was he was trying to be more black
than stephen a was trying to be like it
was almost like
i don't know if you have friends like
this like i look i had friends who tried
so hard to be a gangster and they were
not
i had so friends who were trying so hard
to be cool and they were not i had
friends who were trying so hard to be a
basketball player and they were not
friends who were trying so hard to be
players they were not did you see that
his personality changed from like boxing
yeah to first take because that's the
first thing i noticed was that he wasn't
the same and he was trying to convert
you know he was a rapper before right
max kellerman you guys being sarcastic
or serious no i don't know that max
kellerman was a rapper i could see him
be able to spit a little max kellerman
was a rapper back in the days he had
bars oh yeah he's actually pretty decent
but he's got a music video i can't put
it up right now because they're gonna
they're gonna but he actually was pretty
decent i just wasn't a fan of my here's
why i'm not a fan of the first take show
on how it was when bayless like steven a
gave a lot of credit to bayless he says
i was a nobody bayless brought me up
because bayless was a relevant guy i was
a nobody and it had somebody to go up
against right and they would debate
will kane to me was better than max
kellerman wilkin would destroy max
kellerman stephen a would destroy will
kane but will king could go up again
yeah the challenge is wilkin used to be
a blaze guy he used to be with the blaze
i don't know if you remember what came
from the blaze years ago wilkin used to
work for back espn brought him on board
and then he went straight to fox will
king could end up being one of these
next tucker carlson type of guys
do you remember when tucker carlson was
a nobody 20 years ago and jon stewart
went on their show and destroyed him and
johnson
you guys suck yeah he says you guys suck
you guys are terrible and look at tucker
carlson today yeah talk by the way you
know when they came out with the data on
who they think can be the presidential
candidate for 2024 you know who's fifth
on the list tucker carlson fifth on the
list is tucker carlson number one is
obviously trump two is uh desantis uh
three nikki haley nikki haley's three
there's another one
uh yeah and then five is talking across
no chance how do you put tucker on a top
five so uh i don't know listen espn if
you kept keep tim tebow
good for you i'm betting 70
within three to five years tim tebow's
gonna be fired i hope i'm wrong if they
keep them salute to them right and i
hope tim tebow challenges him in
everything kaepernick does everything
nba does everything lebron does because
sports is no longer just sports it's
political yeah so there has to be an
element of sports today that talks
politics you can't just say sports is
the sports of 20 years ago no
it's no longer before we move on yeah
unless you're a ufc favorite sports
commentator out there he's number one to
you oh yeah yeah stephen how about you
phil you snoop dogg on through
sports personality commentator
oh just told you he was uh i know maybe
it's a dancer no commentator what about
that
for football yeah romo
was a science boy it was a science it
was just amazing when he was breaking it
down peyton manning's legit
i he's
scott van pelt
svp
yeah i'm not a fan yeah
but you looked at me like i was getting
like uh you know i know who you were
talking about okay but you looked at me
like i like offended you
because you didn't i was offended for a
second
who i'm secretly kind of in love with
malika andrews you know who that is
of course pull her up kai malika andrew
malik andrews if you're listening malika
andrews or carrie champion
the fact that i don't even know who
carrie champion is yeah
andrew she is adorable go to that one
right there no third yeah boom
are you kidding me
she's gorgeous
military if you're out there hit up
yeah tinder whatever you like what
that's not how you that's that's not how
you get the girl bro that's not that's
fulfilled no shame in no game wow bro
good luck
just saying she's i think she's pretty
damn adorable
this guy's still kidding so when she
gives her commentating you you don't
listen to anything she says no i do i i
listen very intently no no it's not that
close don't you okay you can you can
remove it let's let's continue let's
continue and you i just struck you down
bro yeah
let's continue by the way speaking of
awesome women let me just give a quick
shout out jennifer but david killed it
on stage
killed it on stage
at the vault yeah and
cherie
heath what a what what a babe awesome
she's awesome respect damn right okay
i'm giving respect appreciate i
appreciate it let's let's continue to go
to your favorite story yes trump and
desantis adam said i want to know if
this is the truth i want to hear from
david harris so we're going to see what
david harris has to say about this and
we're going to see what uh
mr sauce has to say about this so trump
reportedly said he effing hates ron
desantis this is a the weak story
as former president trump possibly as a
2024 run a new report suggests there's
one other potential contender whose
popularity he really resents florida
governor desantis a report from vanity
fair this week delves into our various
republicans are testing the waters for
2024 presidential primaries in case
trump doesn't decide to seek the gop
nomination and among the likely
contenders in that scenario would be
descendants but the report describes
that the
fact that the florida governor's biggest
challenge may be his fraught
relationship with the 45th president
trump often hates the santa's a trump
confidante told vanity fair he just
resents his popularity earlier this year
2024 straw poll taken at the western
conservative summit saw the santa
slightly ahead of trump 74 to 73
so i'm going to go to you first have you
heard anything about the story david
harris jr no
and my first question when you asked me
last night if i even knew about it was
who reported it
because i've got a filter that i've got
to put everything through and every
single individual in america literally
in the world should understand that
you've got to put things through a
filter who's saying it what's their
source uh and is anybody else verifying
that and what's their angle you know
what is the which way do they lean van
dy fair leans
heavily left so far left maybe furthest
left you know they're in the category of
furthest left yeah they're out there
with rolling stone who just got smashed
for uh uh posting a fake news article
against iver mechden saying that
hospitals in ohio were overran with uh
uh with uh people having adverse
reactions to ivermectin so much so that
people that had car accidents couldn't
get in there the whole thing was made up
the whole thing was a lie uh rachel madd
maddow mad cow she ran with it bbc ram
with it so anyway i have a filter so my
my question is who's saying the article
okay they're left-leaning biased
reporting uh agency
and what would their intention be for
this
well
try to create some division amongst
conservatives or at least two democrats
make it look like the higher ups trump
desantis are at odds with each other i
haven't personally heard anything i've
reached out to some connections that are
close with trump i haven't heard back
from them but uh it doesn't make any
sense to me you know the sanctions is
doing exactly what you know he's an
american first america first
governor he's leaving the state open
he's trying to leave the state open he's
allowing people to go to work uh they're
seeing you know their numbers soar as
far as employment um they they have so
many hit pieces against them on you know
the viruses out of control in florida
and then they wind up having to retract
all that because it was total made up
like they literally took data from last
year and plugged it into this year to
try to make it look like they had a
massive resurgence of of covet in
florida so there's a
there's an attack to try to separate and
to make trump look bad or make the
sanders look bad but i haven't heard any
of that and i don't i don't see that
either and i definitely don't see him
actually making a statement that would
go anywhere even if he did for some
other personal reason to have an issue
with the sanders yeah so so you buy into
the comment that obama said uh don't
underestimate uh biden's ability to f
things up oh yeah i can believe that
because yeah i mean can you see that
happening
biden doing something like that he's one
of the greatest
presidents we've had in the last 12
months well yeah sure i'm sorry 81
million people voted for for the guy
most popular president of all time yeah
yeah as he couldn't get 50 people to his
rally which is why they had to start
using jeeps to go in there and honk so i
want you to be careful because he gets
offended when you say things like that
adam gets very all i do is speak the
truth david harris can i ask you a
question sure odds that trump runs in
2024 what you got
i say they're very good i don't want to
hear very good i need numbers baby i'd
say it's 90
90. i don't think that's the question
though i think the question isn't that i
think the question is
who
on the right do they want to be the
leading candidate representing the 2024
meaning
do republicans today want trump or do
they want desantis
they want trump okay so let me ask you
this base that trump built and the the
energy that's in the conservative party
and there's a splintering right because
trump was the outsider so the gop i mean
it's like there is a splintering in the
gop from the republican party that would
rather have desantis they'd rather have
the same sure yeah than trump they say
well trump's too polarizing this that
and the other but you know what i think
more people in this country are fired up
to be conservative and to align with
conservative values which is what
republicans do than ever before in this
country here's a question for you so say
for instance trump says i'm not running
do you think trump will go campaign for
desantis or desantis to win
if that if desantis is the is the guy i
think he would yeah you think he would
yeah so like he is right now with state
uh with uh with congressional races he's
endorsing candidates he's out there he's
pushing you know he said he's not gonna
he he's not gonna just take this this
loss this perceived loss i mean it is
right on paper we got a president on
paper right now uh that's in there
because of fraud and my personal belief
and opinion is absolutely no way that he
should be in office uh and i'm still
holding out for the arizona audits i'm
still holding out to find out what the
audits have to say
uh because i believe that when the
audits come out of arizona they're gonna
decertify their results that's going to
be numb the first state to do it and
then georgia's fault i think georgia's
going to follow suit with the audits
wisconsin's talking about it
pennsylvania what are you asking all
those swing stops that actually happens
dave you know what on my podcast
the david j harris jr podcast on my
podcast for a year
yeah you got to have jay can i have the
j and j stand for james james david
james it's kind of like two bible names
right
well it's just like the middle name
david james harris jr keep going so um
for the better part of a year on my
podcast i would say if for some hail
mary chance of a reason joe biden got in
office
well he's in office
so now i'm saying if if there's a hail
mary chance
that we can get these swing states
to actually do a forensic audit and look
if biden won then all power to him great
everybody that's supporting biden
supports the democrats they should be
happy they should be able to say look we
proved it now shut the hell up great but
if not why are they roadblocking and
stalling these audits from happening
well you're using term like hail mary so
this is a hail mary well it is yeah
anything happens
that's what i'm saying it was a hail
mary chance that biden got in which he
did
what i'm saying right now is what i
truly believe is a way to rectify the
fraud there's no statute of limitations
on until it happens until it happens it
happens i mean i want to stay on topic
here so let's go back on topic here so
how how bad you think it would look
when desantis and trump imagine the
debate stage for republican you know
these two guys are debating okay
you have on stage nikki haley you have
onstage desantis you have on stage pence
you have on stage these guys are
debating right
how ugly will that get if that because
to me the sight of pence and trump
debating that doesn't look right no okay
yeah and do you think desantis
is gonna sit there and allow trump to
take shots at him or do you think
trump's gonna be okay if desantis is
like you know the kamala harris shot at
uh biden do you remember the whole thing
like how awkward that was oh yeah the
sec was it the first debate or second
debate
racist basically called the race
but but how weird will that look to see
desantis trump pence all on stage nikki
haley makes sense but the other three to
be on stage if that were to happen how
competitive do you think it would get it
it it almost seems unimaginable like
that's how i agree with that i almost
want to ask you about how did you see
pence
desantis nikki haley up on stage
debating trump yeah and let's not forget
what trump haley's 2016. haley's fine
no she's got some questionable yeah no
no no no no
what i'm saying is haley doesn't give a
like to go right
now
no no she yeah she'll call her she'll
call him out it almost seems like
they're just gonna give him the
nomination like i don't see trump
remember how ugly things got in 2016
between lion ted cruz and little marco
rubio and the whole cast and sleepy ben
carson and with the whole thing
how ugly it got
i think you know you know what though
with with trump he never really win it
ben
he never went at bin with any shots
carson ben carson yeah he just let ben
be ben right he didn't really have
anything to say i'm almost wondering if
that was the case it's hard to imagine
but if that was the case if we'd
actually just see
them each try to lay out their best plan
for how to move this country forward in
the right direction and unless somebody
has a reason for shots like pence trump
trump's not going to back down off of
that because let me tell you why i
stopped it he could have stopped the the
he could have given another two weeks
back in january to say we need to
actually look at some of this material
instead of moving forward with uh with
certifying the election and pinston do
it what do campaign managers get hired
to do
to win seek industrial rights for you to
win right not for
for you to win
the campaign manager has a lot on the
line if i'm taking desantis and i'm
going to be your campaign manager i'm
asking you a question dude are you
playing to be vp or are you playing to
be the president right because i got to
have a good record as well
so then trump's campaign manager they're
going to do what they do best they're
going to make those short clips go viral
you know because you'd be in jail type
of videos their their social media team
is a freaking beast of a social media
team right yep so he's going to know his
part but i will tell you the sentence is
not a lightweight the santa is not pants
now santa's
desantis believes
he's the president united states the
santas has that identity that i'm going
to be the president united states and i
think i'm the right guy to do the job i
think that's what this and there's a
part of america that believes the same
with him as well
so he'll get ugly huh
i agree that's my concern yeah let me
show you my two cents here's the other
conversation do you think you know how
biden has a meeting with
uh not biden has a meeting the the folks
on potbiten's camp have a meeting with
sanders with elizabeth warren with
everybody like listen guys super tuesday
drop out come support let's go win we
got to beat this trump guy we can't be
dividing right you think there's going
to be somebody that's going to say
desantis okay so let's have the
conversation so visualize this
conversation i'm from trump's camp i go
meet with desantis and i say hey ron
we'd like to have a meeting with you and
they have the meeting behind closed
doors and they say ron uh how much do
you love america
you know how much i love america ron we
think the best thing to do right now is
the following how about you agree
to not go up against trump you become
the vp trump becomes the president
and we go beat
biden and then after trump's done you
win and you become a two-term president
okay visualize that's it's gonna happen
yeah you're ron desantis what do you
think ron's gonna say in that meeting
that's hell no yeah
are you crazy it's it's almost like this
it's almost like i don't know though
because he desantis has to see
the rise in popularity among the
conservatives in the republican party
due to trump the trump effect you can't
deny the manga affect the trump effect
instead of trying to chop trump down and
go after him and potentially lose
he could be a sure bet if he got with
trump and then he could still have the
chance to be president for two more for
two more i don't know if he sees it that
terms i think i don't know it's tough i
think here's what you got to ask him is
he dwyane wade
or is he giannis
is he is he
uh uh uh is he a guy that's gonna be
like hey let's team up and go build a
super team together you know like hey
come on let's build a super team in
cleveland and miami and boston right or
is your guy that's gonna say no i'm good
i can build a team around myself and i
think i'm a good number one i think
you're good number one but i also think
i'm a good number one
i get a feeling that ron thinks he's a
good number one i don't get a feeling
that i think ron thinks he's a number
two there's there's a moment where trump
is bringing ron up this is in 2019 and
trump says
you know i'm not gonna lie to you first
time i met ron i i said you know iran's
a little chubby ron's gotta lose some
weight because i was always worried that
ron's a little heavy you know right he's
a little round he's a little happy he
said this are you saying trump said this
to the santa's bringing him up wow and
he says i'm like he says yeah you kind
of feeling him i'm thinking this guy's a
little heavy he's you know he's got to
lose some weight and trump is saying
this about this he says and then one day
i tap his shoulder when i tap his
shoulder and i felt all the muscles i
said no this guy's not chubby this guy's
muscular this guy's strong he's the only
politician i've said this to he said i
told ron ron you ought to take your
shirt off more often don't wear a jacket
with that being said help me bring up
your governor ron desantis that's how he
brought him up
only trump will bring
[Laughter]
i actually think that there is kept it
real he kept it real unreal i actually
think there is a little bit of
credibility to this story and i'll tell
you why and i get that it's vanity fair
you know how they say you would yeah
credibility to vanity fair he would no
i'm not i don't even care about the
vanities
subscriber to a national inquiry just so
you know i'm going based on
track record
you know how they say the ego is not the
amigo
if this poll is anywhere this is at the
western conservative summit
this ain't vanity fair here david yes
this is a straw poll okay cool it's a
poll the fact that we all know that
trump loves the polls i'm doing great in
the polls
yeah that doesn't validate him saying
something like that about this i'm not
that's not what i'm saying all right
together that's what he's trying to do
that's what he's saying if there was a
poll that's what people that have been
programmed do what i i'm saying if there
is a poll that even shows
desantis beating trump trump doesn't
like that bro love you buddy okay listen
i think we all agree here here's my
prediction trump went runs again
he's not going to win if desantis and
haley win on the tick uh run on the
ticket they can win i think you're
forgetting how toxic trump is i think if
you take a desantis
and a nikki haley you're gonna get
people in the middle to vote for them i
think if you're cool with your 42
percent
you know maybe you get to 45 percent
you're back to oh we got your lecture
stolen from us uh they don't they don't
like trump let me ask you a question let
me ask you a question
go to uh go to uh
anybody after their first term okay
obama after his first term did he have a
terrible first term he did not have a
great first term okay
go to did he have a terrible first term
did he have a terrible second time did
he have a terrible first time what's
that did obama have a terrible first
term he did not have a good first term
but not a terrible i think it was
terrible i don't know okay so do you
think bush gw had a good first term
uh
junior yeah
no with 911 okay let me
do you think uh clinton had a good first
term
yes yes okay
take all of their first terms yes and
even trump do you think trump had a good
first term until kovid but that's not on
his control though because even he
deliberately well he he brought vaccine
within nine months even though everybody
said even found she said 18 months he
delivered within nine months right
that's not because of foundry trump was
dealing with all these other guys that
brought it okay so today if we look at
trump as a fur term first term was it a
great first term good first term
terrible first term or bad first term
depends on the the lens that you're
looking at zero to ten
for uh let's say
even for you say five or six sure okay
who between trump obama gw
bill clinton had a worse first term
those four or biden so far i mean just
based on what happened to the country
you have to say george w bush with
katrina with 911 okay so you put him
first worst term first term yeah you put
biden uh uh uh biden i mean he's been in
less than a year so it's like it only
took a year for him to break everything
i mean
he didn't need a whole four years some
people don't need four years more
competitively
jimmy carter every day thanks god saying
thank you for your favorite president of
all time jimmy carter is officially
taken off the list he's officially taken
off the list i don't think that biden is
doing great okay
at all uh
is less than a year ago i don't know
where i'm going with this where i'm
going with this is you forget the fact
that depending on how big does he makes
it easy for anybody to say we gotta try
something i don't think biden should run
again in 2024 oh you want kamala as a
partner i know i don't think he's going
to you want his first term pelosi
not pelosi i think look i think there
should be a rule if you're over 70 peace
out
peace out for moving forward peace out
really trump biden pelosi so who are you
the judge guy
what's that buddha judge no i'm not but
i think he's a talented guy but i'm not
a buddha judge guy i just think
again i'll say this again for those that
weren't listening i think if desantis
and nikki haley run on that ticket they
can win if you throw toxic trouble
against independence and some democrats
that's what i'm saying dave all right we
all know that if you're a conservative
and you're a maga guy you love trump
but nobody else does bro like do you i
love that policies it's not about the
man although i appreciate him okay met
him 10 11 times how many people vote on
policies well they're gonna say they're
gonna start to because of what's going
on i don't think so i think that
argument of
forget about the candidate forget about
the candidate put a blank picture of the
candidate and just look at their
policies well if we keep going
i don't think anybody does that i think
it's an emotional
attachment to who the candidate is and
people were emotional there's some
pizzazz in there right somebody gets up
that's the whole world
people want to see somebody and how
they're going to interact how they're
going to talk of course what's the
what's the percentage right now of
people wanting to retract their vote
from 20 percent it was 20 right 1 in 5.
out of 80 million people
that that's that's enough that's what 20
million
16 million people okay so that alone and
by the way secretly you're part of that
camp as well though no i don't pull the
lever for biden again i will tell you
this desantis do you vote for my nikki
haley you have a chance you vote for
biden toxic trump
you have no chance adam yes sir you vote
for biden when
in 2020 yes
okay you regret your vote yet
i don't regret my vote but i think uh
biden has some cleaning up to do
how
all he's done is make messes so far well
like a little kid crapping in his
diapers that's some of the some of the
looks that biden does after he says
something it's that look that he gets
it's a look a little kid has again
this is how i look at it we've had this
conversation already my the way i look
at it is the following who's a good
number one
okay biden's not a good number one but
nobody voted for him to be like they
were like we got a drunk driver
somewhere
that's why people what i'm saying today
people are starting to realize you don't
vote for number four to be a number one
right you don't do that correct gerald
ford was never a good number one he's a
good number two or three
h.w bush he was never a good number one
and that's why he didn't get uh elected
a second time right who didn't senior
senior no no no he didn't get elected
the second time because he got cocky
thinking he's going to win a roster
so that's a very different anomaly you
just brought in no that's he wasn't
really a true number one
uh i think on against the people he was
going up against but i also think ross
pearl was the number one yeah i think
ross pros are number one are you kidding
me i think ross pro was a fully good
number one so you have the look no but
the but it sounds so so the challenge
i'm having right now is desantis is a
number one
so is trump that's what i'm trying to
say pence i don't think pence should run
no i think people behind closed doors
that are telling them to run i think
should say nothing i think should say
just stay there because pence's legacy
right now is not that bad it's not great
but pence's legacy believe it or not
remember when trump first announced
pence what do people say like what pence
and then you got to know him you're like
you know what and no yeah he's like cool
yeah he's likable and he's pink steve
has vanilla
but that's exactly what trump needed i
agree yeah yeah that's why he was a good
selection so let me go to the next story
so if you don't believe that story
melania trump is telling her friends
that she has no interest in being first
lady again despite her husband's 2024
teases report this is an insider story
uh several of melania trump's friends
told cnn she had no interest in
returning to the white house let alone
helping if her husband decided to run
former president trump hasn't declared a
2024 candidacy but has teased the
possibility saying her his supporters
will be very happy with his decision
previous reports said melania trump was
happy and relaxed since exiting the
white house earlier this year she
largely remained out of the public eye
unlike some of her podesta's
predecessors and has
made a few public appearances so do you
think she really wants to be a first
lady again zero percent no i agree so if
i have to believe one of these two
stories i think this is the one i
believe in because i don't think she
ever wanted that kind of no eyeballs i
think she just wanted to be at peace
just kidding i hate yeah yeah the toxic
i mean it was so toxic how is that gonna
play a role if he because i 100 think
trump's running again you're saying
you're at 90 percent you're at where
i'm gonna ask him when i interview him
in three weeks i like i'm sure he'll
double the question like he's been
ducking the question i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna put it i'm gonna
i need to guess
uh as close to 100 as possible okay so
you're 90 100 100 and that only that
only ten is looking at if we can if we
can get the election integrity laws
passed and stop the massive voter id
uh debacle that is what stole the last
election
we can't have mass mail in voting like
that we've got to have voter id laws
there's got to be something in place to
make sure that we as americans all of us
no matter what side of the aisle we're
on can have trust and faith in the
election process i think we can all hope
whether you're on left or the right that
covet is not here in 2020 freaking force
wait what are you talking about what are
you talking about i hope that it's not a
major factor like in this process
stop it
you
okay are you serious listen in a game of
war when you see a play that works you
have to figure out a way
to use it again and again this this was
a proven form they're going to remix it
they're doing it how many different
variants are there right now they're
doing it now mailing ballots work
for fraud does mail-in ballots work
to get as creative as you want as
possible i don't care whether you
believe whatever happened here listen
biden's the president today
but does mail-in ballots work to be able
to manipulate more than you coming and
showing your idea obviously okay so so
to me i'm not even saying that happened
or didn't happen all i'm saying to you
is you can get more creative with mail
and balance than you can
with ids you think they're going to let
that go
no way listen when you play football
you're gonna you're gonna continue the
same play if they cannot stop your
running back what do you do keep running
through the middle they can't stop keep
running until you found a play to stop
it i'm running through your linebackers
because your guys suck today they're
gonna figure right away covet may not be
around 20 23 something's going to be
around 20 20 23 to create a shutdown but
that's why what david is saying as far
as the oddest is so important let me
give you a flip perspective she'll give
you a flip perspective okay if you're
saying that's the playbook shut it down
i think that would actually be a bad
look on biden his whole candidacy is
like i'm gonna take care of coaches no
you don't i'm gonna take care of you and
if it's still around 2024. do you
remember
him to a community i'm at a restaurant
uh the lady outside she's sitting there
she's saying let me tell you something i
cannot believe in the state of florida i
don't see anybody wearing a masculine
valley with a mask on what an
irresponsible no wonder all of these
people in the state of florida are so
sick look at these no one has a mask on
she's hollering at me and i don't have a
mask on i'm outside waiting for my car
so man where are you outside i see ma'am
where are you
yeah i said man where are you from i'm
from the responsible state
of california i said oh really yeah says
well you know there's a reason why so
many people are leaving your state
because they're being forced to do
things they don't want to do which means
what there is a group of people that
think shutting down is the responsible
thing to do and you're forgetting that
audience there's a group of people that
say dude what a what a responsible guy
here knew some you know oh my gosh reed
hastings is he a pretty smart guy he's a
hunter on netflix he runs a 200 billion
dollar company is he pretty a smart guy
he's pretty smart he gave three million
dollars to newsom to keep him in there
why is he do you think he reedson is a
dummy no there's a group of people that
think what he's doing is right well dude
think about it if you're the ceo of
netflix you don't want people going to
the damn movie theater you want people
at home watching tv
yeah even even if that's the argument
even if that's the argument
even if that's the argument even if
that's the argument still he's not a
dummy there are a lot of smart people
that have done well for themselves that
are going to support a nuisance that are
going to support somebody that stays
home rather than going to work yeah
there's a lot of people that are
lobbying for that so a lot of people are
people that support communism and hate
capitalism too i don't we're not here to
disagree on that point all i'm saying to
you is when it comes down to 2023 2024
there's a group of people that think
it's responsible to shut down rather
than leaving it open for people to
decide by the way some of those guys you
just mentioned are some of pat's closest
friends don't offend pat he talks to
communists all the time uh i've probably
integrated more communists than anybody
else on youtube from a capitalistic
standpoint
so let's go let's go what you do you
wake anybody up yet
non-stop that's what we do
two stories before we wrap up one adam
sandler says netflix asked him to
rewrite his new movie
so it wasn't set in china because the
company doesn't do business there page
five i'll go to this and then we'll wrap
up with taliban uh and i wanna hear your
thoughts on that uh this is page six
adam sandler top of six is it six or
five six okay six
let me see where it's at six did i miss
it right here we go
so adam sanders
okay in the forthcoming comedy hustle
sander plays a basketball agent who
attempts to revive the failing career by
recruiting an extraordinary overseas
talent to the nba in the final version
the film sanders character recruits a
promising player promising player from
spain played
by the real-life memphis grizzlies
forward juancho hernan gomez sandler
says it was written originally that i
find a player in china and somehow
netflix is not in china so they were
like would you guys please make it so we
find someone in latin or latin america
or europe last year netflix ceo reed
hastings told cnbc that the company was
not focused on cracking the chinese
market what do you think about this
interesting yeah very interesting to me
because you got a big market in china
yeah and he's sitting there saying yeah
i don't think if that's the market we
want to get into because i don't think
we're going to win period right if we go
there because what's really going to
happen they're going to see what we're
doing year and a half later they're
going to take all our
you know method of doing business then
we're out they're going to oust us
anyways so it's not a winning
proposition for us to try to compete in
china what's this thing interesting do
you agree do you agree with his uh uh
point of view is that reid hastings or
hastings yeah this is interesting
because we just talked about i know we
just took a shot at him
the fact that he's like no i'm not going
to china not worth it it's essentially
he's basically saying i'm not worried
about making more money in china why do
people go to china why does the nba go
to the china why does nike go to china
for the money baby for the freaking
money yeah and uh he's basically saying
we're good we're going to go everywhere
else in the world we're not going to go
to china respect to him
i agree with you no matter how even if
it's his own personal you know uh
motives motivation that he's that he's
doing it we gotta we should stop doing
everything with china yeah he's
respecting his ip you know big time yeah
yeah by the way a little little fun fact
this
honcho hernan gomez i think there's a
couple brothers that play in the nba
these are gomez
over the weekend while we print this out
he got traded to the boston celtics so
he's no longer on the mountain god
so what's there what's the brothers
investment uh there's uh
because one of them one of them played
for the nuggets and i used to watch them
yeah and then he got traded to the
knicks yeah yeah there's a couple look
the saul brothers the collins brothers
uh the holiday brothers there's there's
some bro there's some brothers in the
league and not the few brothers
not the brothers brothers but like
actual brothers so these hernan gomez
guys you know well we're glad you
cleared that up for yeah thank you for
everyone very hard
next taliban declared china their
closest ally this is a telegraph story
china is the taliban's principal
partner in the international community
the islamist group has said it is its
strongest signal yet of diplomatic
priorities taliban spokesman
zabiola
on thursday claimed beijing was ready to
invest and reconstruct afghanistan as he
set out hopes that china would provide a
gateway to global markets mr mujad said
that the chinese would revive afghan
copper mining and production as the
express admiration for the one belt uh
one road project under which china
extends significant lows to
the other countries to invest in
infrastructure western critics have
framed the initiative as a debt trap
that helped chinese extend uh
geopolitical influence a charge rejected
by chinese leaders david i'm going to go
to you first with this one
so
the taliban wants a seat at the table
they want to see it at the g7
they want to be recognized as a world
leader
um on my podcast over the last couple
weeks i've had a very close friend of
mine victor marks
who's been
to afghanistan he's got a house still in
iraq
he's a former marine he's a veteran his
his co is a delta guy jeff
and he's got assets on the ground that
whole pineapple express that we heard
about where the veterans went in and
actually rescued thousands doing doing
more for americans that than this
administration was doing
kennedy tim what uh
yeah so
victor's team is a part of that
coalition that tim kennedy is a part of
chad uh uh
pineapple expo
express yeah so he shared with me
because
right before we pulled out right before
biden pulled out i'd say wouldn't say
weeks i don't think most americans don't
believe that we should have left the way
that we did the withdrawal shouldn't
happen the way that it did and americans
are still left behind i was worried that
we were going to start to see some of
these you know just straight up
executions you know throats getting slit
talibans just you know that's what
they're gonna do
and victor helped bring me down and gave
me a lot of peace to just think about
he's like they're looking at the
long-term play here the taliban's
looking at now they've got control of
afghanistan there's three trillion
dollars in minerals in the soil in
afghanistan
and they want to seed at the table they
want to be recognized as a world leader
they want to they want to have a say-so
at the g7
so china coming in
giving them the the being becoming a
partner with them giving them the rights
to be able to go and mine it's going to
help them of course absolutely
diplomatically and they're sitting on a
gold mine of americans they they want to
ransom these americans they want to sell
them back to us basically they want they
want to get paid so i don't think we're
going to see slaughter i think we're
going to see what we're already hearing
some of the reports that taliban's not
letting americans leave
they want they want ransom payments made
and here we've got china that is just
continuing to you know make their their
marks bigger and stronger with more
connections and here we've got the
little united states of america with joe
biden at the helm
not a real leader and somebody that's
afraid to tell the taliban what we
should do and what we will do instead
he's taking orders okay we'll be out by
the 31st you know okay we'll do this and
that it's just it's an absolute mess but
the taliban is is
yeah and china connecting is absolutely
something that we that the world should
be very very concerned about
i think um
what this does is kind of come down to
alignment everything's kind of falling
into place based on who your homies are
all right it's like what am i getting at
what's the correlation between china and
the taliban because that's not exactly
like they've been
in cahoots
the common denominator is pakistan china
has been influencing pakistan they've
invested in pakistan pakistan clearly
has been in cahoots with the taliban al
qaeda all all that fun stuff
who has the united states been you know
in alignment with india so india is the
regional power over there india
and pakistan have major beef it's kind
of
it's kind of like you know the the axis
and the axis of evil and the allies kind
of all taking place so
it's kind of like draft picks if you're
playing five on five all right i got
this guy all right i got this guy united
states drafted uh india china drafted
pakistan pakistan comes with a taliban
we've got certain this country over here
and that's essentially what's taking
place here it is concerning that the
taliban is aligning with china best
friends with china are you surprised
i'm not because again they're aligned
with pakistan that's why i'm not
surprised yeah no i i the china is going
to align with anybody who hates america
yep yep what do you what are you talking
about like the phone call you got to
make is uh can we make a list of
countries that hate america who's at the
top china okay make a phone call right
exactly we'll take iran we'll take north
korea we'll take russia that's on our
team whereas the united states will take
india we'll take israel we'll take the
united kingdom anyone that hates anyone
that hates democracy and that's what i'm
saying when they hate our democracy
well look at the one built one road
project i mean that's so freaking huge
yeah you know shout out to uh general
robert spalding for a stealth war book
guys i've been talking about these books
ever since it came out
you guys need to start reading it i mean
basically let out you know
he just laid out the freaking playbook i
mean and it's and it's very unfortunate
that it actually is playing out because
you know you got you got americans
literally on social media
liking certain communism you know
feeds
and they have no freaking clue what's
happening right now and what's going to
happen as
china alliance aligns themselves with
people like the taliban i mean this is
this is very dangerous this is not for
play i'm going to keep saying this i'm
going to keep saying this because
i think there's china's number one enemy
today
that they fear china has learned they
can control america yeah easy they're
already here yeah they have figured out
a formula because the the the challenge
with a lot of people in america
politicians that can be bought money all
this stuff it's very easy to buy america
today
china's got the formula they're killing
it more power to them on their strategy
they're obviously enemy but all i'm
saying is yeah they outsmarted american
politics right but there's one country
they despise there's only one country
they despise i pulled up data the other
day we're looking at ages do you know
the average age
of population in u.s what is the average
age we have 330 million give or take
people living in the u.s guess what's
the average age of an american today 40
45 80.
i'm sorry averaging you say 42 you're
pretty close what do you think it is i
was thinking mid-40s okay 38.1 okay
millennials are the largest generation
baby boomers before that 38. what do you
think is the average age of a ch uh up
uh citizen in china lower than that what
do you think it is no i would say higher
than that 38.4 okay by the way not that
far 38.1 38.4 what do you think is the
average age of someone in india
in their late 20s
what do you think no idea 26 years old
yeah wow 26 to 38. look india is going
to surpass china they fear india like
you don't even if i'm us if i'm us
biting won't do it whoever is the next
president that needs to do this if i'm
us
if i want to protect
the world long term to make sure a china
doesn't i'm doing whatever i can to
strengthen india with our relationship
anything i can to do to strengthen them
that's where i'm going because the same
game these guys are playing you got to
go to the one person they fear the most
it's like that one person a guy doesn't
want his you know the the family to talk
to or girl to talk to or you know a
person to find out about who's that one
person china fears if india gets
stronger right i'm going to do whatever
i can to strengthen india today because
china is going to shiver if india gets
stronger because china is getting older
that whole one baby rule backfired on
them okay that one baby rule is what got
the average should be 38.4 and fyi
america's not as young as we're acting
like we are we're only 38.1 it's like
china and u.s is about the same age
india is 26. so there is a there is a
savior there for the world and it's
india so you want to you want to team up
with taliban no problem with china you
go team up with taliban hey here's what
we're going to do you got 75 000 taliban
people you just teamed up with good for
you china we just teamed up with one and
a half billion right let me tell you
what we're going to be doing we're going
to strengthen them let's create a
partnership and go tell the world about
it that's what i would be doing but
there's a democracy let's not forget
democracy democracy and dictatorships
align they are brilliant they are great
engineers they're willing to work they
are hungry for information they want to
learn they have their own bollywood they
have they're creative
they have so many different benefits
there's so much to build out there
they're passionate people super
passionate people they got a rich
history as well there's some areas with
mindset that can be improved but they
got strong school iit has won the best
engineering school in the world some
will say it's even better than mit in
the u.s so anyways i think china fears
india i agree so i agree my whole talk
about alignment and i give the analogy
of the draft picks if you have the two
great powers these days united states
and china and we have our first pick
we're taking india yeah if it's taliban
china just picked up a scrappy player
you know you're building a basketball
team they just picked up a scrappy
player yeah but you know who india is
india is a guy you can build a team so
first round draft pick not only a first
round he is a shack this is a india
this is the franchise
the franchise player dynasty is like a
like a patrick beverly that's a guy's
robin's too good dude yeah yeah i would
put a beverly
so what do you think what's going on
with hawaii right now what are you
seeing what's going on with hawaii with
some of the restrictions they've created
in hawaii maybe we can wrap up with that
and then go into your book and then
we'll finish up the podcast it looks
like australia i mean it looks i mean
the the democrat uh the democrats in
charge over there in hawaii i've got
people that are reaching out to me like
crazy
um i posted a video of a chief a a
fire captain that had been been there 20
years
that they are forcing the jab on people
in order to work even their their
servicemen from hospitals to fire to
police
uh they're making it like a police state
like what we're seeing in australia and
it's not going to get any better i don't
think in these states that have these
democrat governors and and
you know our democrat majority they're
they're going to try to take as much as
they can they're going to use fear to
try to put people in the box to make
people think like it's a responsible
thing to do because they're being
programmed
because they they want full power
control it's leading to socialism and
it's happening one state at a time and
it's horrible what's happening in hawaii
the beautiful thing is it is waking
people up and people that have been on
the sideline
hoping things are going to get better
believing that things are going to get
better but not having a dog in the fight
not being vocal about it they're getting
vocal so i believe i hope and pray and
believe that what's happening in in
hawaii what's happening in california
what's happening in new york with the
the mandates there in new york uh
businesses just saying hey you can't
even go into businesses unless you've
been vaccinated yeah we see an uprising
take place from the people that have not
been vocal and i think that's what it's
going to take in order to really turn
things around yeah i mean the biggest
thing is options man choices that's the
biggest thing have choices for people
the other day i saw a poll
uh what percentage of americans believe
it's okay to expect a
a a vaccine uh passport to travel 63
are agreeing that
that airlines should make it okay wow
for you to seek by the way
internationally
that's a real number by the way 63 and
don't be surprised if it gets there
if it gets to the point where you are
forced to do that
that's going to change the game for a
lot of people some of them are going to
be in the middle saying i don't get the
shot some of them are not going to get
shot what's going to happen what
business is going to take up land a lot
of people can travel private you can't
afford twenty seven thousand dollars a
flight to go somewhere
you're gonna be spending money so it's
it's a
very interesting direction we're going
as a country uh david jay harris jr tell
us about your book why i couldn't stay
silent
for people that want a perspective for
why an individual and somebody in the
black community is a conservative
supported trump did not support obama
i get into what i believe is the new kkk
of today uh the kkk's wholesale mission
was to
manipulate dominating control and i
believe that that's exactly what the
mainstream media the liberal the
majority of the liberal mainstream media
is doing today it's not just lynching
people out in the streets but it's
lynching a person's public voice it's
like i've been banned on youtube uh i'm
constantly getting threatened and having
my my voice
diminished on facebook on instagram on
twitter twitter just continues to
to do that so i get into that i would
get into
what i believe the new civil rights
movement is
of today
and uh ford written by candace owens a
great friend of mine
uh loved what she wrote in there about
me and i think the greatest chapter
actually in there is the chapter that my
wife put in there it's a short chapter
but uh beautiful story behind it um when
i shared that video when i when my when
my page started when i the reason i
created a page was i started at the
beginning the after the third debate
between trump and hillary i hopped on
and i ranted for like 14 minutes i had
like 1500 friends on facebook didn't
have any platform it was a very pro-life
message i shared as a christian as a
husband as a father as a business owner
and as a member of the black community
and it's in that order for me my
identity is not in my skin color
my identity is in who i am in christ
first and then who he's made me to be as
a husband to my bride as a father to my
kids i'm an active member of my local
community i am a part of the black
community but my identity is not in my
skin color so i ran and i raved i went
off on what i felt was at stake for this
country when we were looking at face
between choosing between trump and
hillary it was a very pro-life message
and i shared why that was
my wife then became vocal about the fact
that
her mom was in the abortion clinic and
about to abort her
and on the table waiting for the doctor
to come in
she decided to get up and leave wow
and she had that little baby girl
that grew up and became my wife
i wouldn't be the man i am today
we wouldn't have the two amazing
beautiful daughters that we have
if it wasn't for her mom
who didn't have the greatest
circumstances the husband the father was
not going to be in the picture
she didn't think she could handle
raising a kid if she hadn't had the
courage to choose life
my bride wouldn't be here
so she shared that and about a year
after i posted that first video and my
wife posted that a friend of mine
reached out to me and he said you know i
was
i had a friend that was pregnant and was
debating having an abortion and i didn't
know if i'd have the right words to say
so i sent her your video and i sent to
your wife's
story
and he said here's a picture of little
baby ian wow she decided to have a baby
so that in its entirety is in there i
think that's the greatest message and i
think that for people to just get on
if we got on the same
page it's never okay to harm a child who
would ever sit back and watch anybody do
any kind of physical damage
to a little kid nobody would i wouldn't
i don't think anybody at this table
would
so what separates the little inch and a
half
of
the belly to the baby that's inside the
belly
if we could all get on the same page
when roe v wade was was enacted science
they didn't have what we have now right
now we know it's not just a cluster of
cells right now we know a baby has a
heartbeat at five six weeks
it can feel pain it has its own fingers
and toes it has its own dna it's not a
part of the woman's body
it's a body in its entirety and if
people just came together on that
and then supported individuals that
supported life for me i say if it's
often somebody's moral compass
that that's an actual baby inside there
and they're okay doing damage to that
baby what else is off with their moral
compass if we could just align with that
especially believers those people of
faith out there but you don't have to be
a person of faith science now proves it
and backs it up as well that it's a baby
so i get into a lot in there
and if a person wants to know they can
get at davidharrisjunior.com
we're going to put the link below to
your book thank you for that testimony
sharing it with us kai put in the
comment sections and put in the
chat box as well gang if you enjoyed
today's podcast order his book smash the
subscribe button on the channel david if
you can
autograph my book as well
uh having said that folks uh hope you
enjoyed today's podcast
uh i'm sure we're gonna bring david back
in the future again uh with that being
said adam phil david thanks guys take
care everybody we'll do it again this
thursday i think we got a special guest
this thursday no i think michael francis
is going to be here this thursday to
talk about mafia states of america
i think michael will be here in two days
so make sure you join us as well this
thursday on the podcast take care bye
bye bye bye
you